welcome back everyone this is part 8 in
our series on contextual representations
we're going to talk briefly about
sequence to sequence architectures
to kick it off I thought I would begin
with tasks these are going to be tasks
that have natural sequence to sequence
structure and I'm trying to leave open
for now whether we would actually model
them with sequence to sequence
architectures that's a separate question
seek to seek tasks include machine
translation of course this is a classic
one where a text in one language comes
in and we would like to produce text in
another language as the output
summarization also a classic seek to
seek problem a long text comes in and a
presumably shorter one comes out
summarizing the input
free form question answering where we're
trying to generate answers this could
also be a seek to seek problem where a
question maybe with some contextual
information comes in and the task in
decoding is to generate an answer
dialogue of course Classics seek to seek
problem utterances to utterances
semantic parsing could also be thought
of as a seek to seek task here natural
language sentences come in and we try to
map them to their logical forms
capturing aspects of their meaning
related tasks would be code generation
here in natural language sentence comes
in and we try to produce a program that
the sentence is describing
and that is just a small sample of the
many things that we could call seek to
seek tasks and even these are just
special cases of the more General class
of things that we might call encoder
decoder problems which would be agnostic
about whether the encoding and decoding
involves sequences that could involve
images video speech and so forth
I've been offering Historical Notes
throughout this series of lectures and I
think this is a nice point to emphasize
that the RNN era really primed us to
think about seek to seek problems in the
context of Transformers
on the left here I have a classic RNN
formulation of a seek to seek problem
where we have the input sequence A B C D
and then we begin decoding with this
special symbol decode XYZ and then we
produce our n token and that is the job
of decoding the historical note here is
that those tasks evolved from standard
rnns into rnns with lots of attention
mechanisms on the top here designed
specifically to help the decoding steps
remember what was in the encoding part
by offering all of these attention
mechanisms back into that encoding phase
and what we see again in the Transformer
paper is a full Embrace of attention as
the primary mechanism and a dropping
away of all of these recurrent
mechanisms here
in the context of Transformers we have a
variety of ways that we could think
about seek to seek problems one of them
being encoder decoder but other options
present themselves this is a nice figure
from the T5 paper which we'll talk about
in a second on the left you have encoder
decoder as I said where we fully encode
the input in the encoder side with some
set of parameters and then possibly
different parameters do decoding where
in the decoding steps we attend fully
back to all the steps from the encoder
but we needn't have this encoder decoder
structure another option for example
would be to Simply process these
sequences with a standard language model
so in the middle here you have a
Transformer based language model and you
can see that characteristic attention
mask where we don't get to look into the
future but rather can only attend to the
Past even for the part that we're
thinking of as the encoded part
an obvious variation of that would be to
take our language model and when we do
encoding do a full attention connection
set across all the things that we're
doing in coding that's what you can see
reflected here where when we're doing
encoding just as in the encoder decoder
structure we can have every element
attend to every other element and then
here when we start to do decoding that's
where the mask can only look into the
past and not the future
so that's a nice framework for thinking
about this and the middle and right hand
options have become increasingly
prominent as people have explored ever
larger variants of the GPT architecture
which is a standard language model
but I'm going to focus now on two
encoder decoder releases that I think
are very powerful beginning with T5
which was the source of that nice
previous framework there
T5 is an encoder decoder variant that
had extensive multitask supervised and
unsupervised training across lots of
different tasks and then one very
Innovative thing that they did in the T5
paper which really gives us a glimpse of
what was about to happen with in-context
learning is that they offered task
prefixes like translate English to
German colon and then you got the true
input and so that instruction on the
left is kind of telling the model what
we want to do in decoding and it guides
the model in this case to do translation
but the same part after the colon could
be performing a sentiment task given a
different description of the task before
the colon wonderfully insightful thing
where we express all these tasks as
natural language which we simply encode
and that guides the model's Behavior
essentially as though those task
instructions were themselves structured
information as inputs to the model
for T5 we have lots of model releases as
well which has been tremendously
empowering this is a sample of the
models that are available on hugging
face and you can see that they range
from very manageable 60 million
parameter models on up to really large
11 billion parameter releases
relatedly the flan T5 models are
variants of the T5 architecture that
were specifically instruction tuned and
that's a set of methods that we'll talk
about in the next unit of the course
those are also very powerful
so that's T5 the other architecture that
I thought I would highlight here is Bart
Bart has some similarities and some real
differences with T5 the essence of Bart
is that on the encoding side we're going
to have a standard Bert like
architecture
and on the decoding side we're going to
have a standard gpt-like architecture
that's fairly straightforward what's
interesting about bart is the way
pre-training happens this is essentially
oriented around
taking corrupted sequences as input and
figuring out how to uncorrupt them so
what they did on the corrupting side is
for example text infilling where whole
parts of the input are masked out or
removed sentence shuffling where we
reorganize parts of the input token
masking token deletion and document
rotation
and what they found is that the most
effective pre-training regime was a
combination of that text and filling
step and the sentence shuffling step and
remember the idea here is that in
pre-training we're feeding in these
corrupted sequences with these two
techniques by and large and having the
model learn to uncorrupt those sequences
and the idea there which is similar to
the Insight that we had from Elektra is
that that kind of task can lead the
model to understand what good sequences
look like
so that's the pre-training phase if you
download parameters from hugging face
they're likely to be pre-trained in this
kind of uncorrupting fashion
for fine-tuning the protocol is a little
bit different if we're doing
classification tasks we feed uncorrupted
copies of the input into the encoder and
the decoder and then maybe we fine-tune
the final decoder State as we would with
GPT against our classification task and
for standard seek to seek problems we
simply feed in the input and the output
to the model and then fine tune it on
that basis with no corruption the
corruption is by and large confined to
the pre-training phase and the evidence
that the is offered in the paper is that
that kind of objective puts models in a
good pre-trained state where they're
really good at these fine tuning tasks
across a lot of different tasks
so that's T5 and Bart that's just two
samples from the wide range of different
seek to seek architectures that are out
there but I think they're both very
powerful as pre-trained artifacts that
you can make use of and also highlight
some of the Innovation that is happening
with Transformers in the seek to seek
space